all right let's get this kicked off it's
okay to be gay or somewhere in between
we all are part of one big family you
are enough here at queer kid stuff
[Music]
opening a performance with lyrics like
it's okay to be gay for a roomful of
adults is one thing but it's entirely
different for a roomful of
kindergarteners what you just heard is
the theme song for my web series queer
kids stuff where I make lgbtq+ and
social justice videos for all ages and
when I say all ages I mean literal
babies to your great-great-grandma now I
know what you're thinking whoa they're
talking about gay stuff with kids but
talking to kids about gay stuff is
actually crucial the American Academy of
Pediatrics has found that children have
a solid understanding of their gender
identity by the age of four this is when
children are developing their sense of
self they're observing the world around
them absorbing that information and
internalizing it now most parents want
their children to become kind and
pathetic self-confident adults and
exposure to diversity is an important
part of that social and emotional
development and gender non-conforming
kids and trans kids and kids with trans
and non-binary and queer parents are
everywhere
in the series my stuffed bear co-host
and I talked about the LGBTQ community
activism gender and pronouns consent and
body positivity we tackle these topics
through songs not unlike the one you
just heard simple definitions and
metaphors we approach these ideas to
steal a phrase from an old professor of
mine from under the doorknob getting
down to toddler height and looking up at
the great big world through their tiny
little eyes taking these seemingly
complex ideas and simplifying them not
summing them down but homing in on the
core concept gender is about how we feel
and how we express ourselves sexuality
is about love and gender and family not
about sex and these are all ideas
children can grasp in one of my earliest
episodes about gender I used the idea of
pronouns to underscore the definition
and introduced gender-neutral pronouns
like they and then I encourage children
to think about their own pronouns and to
ask others for theirs in later episodes
I build on this foundation and introduce
big fancy words like non-binary and
transgender I get emails from viewers in
their 20s who use my videos to explain
non-binary gender to their grandparents
but I get one comment over and over
again let kids be kids well that's a
nice sentiment all but only if it
actually includes all kids just a few
weeks ago a fifteen-year-old in
Huntsville Alabama died by suicide after
being bullied for being gay in 2018 it
was a seven year old in Denver Colorado
there have been and will be many more
lesbian gay and bisexual teens are more
than three times more likely to attempt
suicide than their heterosexual peers
and transgender teens are almost six
times more likely a court
to one study roughly one-third of
homeless youth identify as lesbian gay
bisexual or questioning and about 4% of
homeless youth identify as transgender
compared with 1% of the general youth
population surveyed according to the
Human Rights Campaign there have been
128 killings of trans people in 87
cities across 32 states since 2013 and
those are only the reported cases and
80% of those killings or of trans women
of color the queer situation is bleak to
say the least the YouTube comments on my
videos are not much better I'm used to
the harassment I get messages daily
telling me I'm a pedophile and that I
should kill myself in a number of
increasingly creative ways I once had to
put the word truck on my block list
because someone wanted me to get run
over by a truck shower and oven are in
there too for the less creative and more
disturbing the Holocaust reference when
neo Nazis marched in Charlottesville
I was unsurprised to learn that the
creator of a violent reddit meme about
one of my episodes was in the tiki torch
crowd this barrage of negativity is what
we're up against the crushing statistics
the violence the mental health risks the
well-meaning but flawed response my
parents gave me when I came out that
they didn't want me to have a harder
life that's what we're up against but in
the face of all that I choose joy I
choose rainbows and unicorns and glitter
and I sing that it's okay to be gay with
my childhood stuffed teddy bear I make
queer media for kids because I wish I
had this when I was their age
I make it so others don't have to
struggle through what I did not
understanding my identity because I
didn't have any exposure to who
I could be I teach and spread this
message through joy and positivity
instead of framing it around the
hardships of queer life I want kids to
grow up and into themselves with pride
for who they are and who they can be no
matter who they love or what they wear
or what pronouns they use and I want
them to love others for their
differences not in spite of them
I think fostering this pride and empathy
will make the world a kinder and more
equal place and combat the bigotry and
hate that Fester's in our world so talk
to a kid about gender talk to a kid
about sexuality teach them about consent
tell them it is okay for boys to wear
dresses and for girls to speak up let's
spread radical queer joy thank you
[Applause]